[Música]
y llegamos a buenos aires porque un juez
argentino cerró el lunes un caso contra
el presidente alberto fernández y la
primera dama fabiola yáñez por violación
de la estricta cuarentena que él mismo
había ordenado en el año 2020 para así
evitar la propagación del comit 19 esto
tras convalidar un acuerdo económico
como reparación del caso olivos gate un
juez federal
hablamos de lino mirabelli y aceptó la
donación de 3 millones de pesos
argentinos equivalentes a unos 14 mil
quinientos treinta dólares americanos de
la pareja para ser así destinados al
sistema de salud público en el marco de
los mecanismos de reparación
contemplados para la resolución de
conflictos o judiciales esta propuesta
ya contaba con el aval previo del fiscal
de este caso fernando domínguez el
magistrado dispuso un plazo de diez días
para efectuar este pago
entonces vamos a hablar conectamos de
inmediato con natalio coso el
corresponsal de france el 24 en la
capital argentina a natalio muy buena
mañana un gusto saludar saludarlos es
and haas y la controversia con el pago
de esta multa o como puede verse
afectado el mandatario argentino natalio
hola que tal buenos dias zanja en el
plano judicial en el plano social es más
difícil saberlo me gustaría recordar que
al inicio de su mandato en los primeros
meses en marzo fernández insistía en una
idea que él luego sostuvo en otras
ocasiones de que con su mandato se
acababa el país de los bobos de los
vivos que pasaban por sobre los bobos
que se aprovechaban y que no cumplían
con las reglas y eso caló muy fuerte con
el contraste de lo que ocurrió en esa
fiesta que tuvo lugar en julio del 2020
cuando era sumamente estricta la
cuarentena en argentina y el presidente
insistía en sus alocuciones en la
obligatoriedad del cumplimiento de las
normas normas que en realidad de no
cumplir se imponían incluso penas de
cárcel como explicaba por supuesto a
través del acuerdo judicial y es algo
que permite el código penal no tuvo que
pagar pena de cárcel logró resolverlo de
forma económica pero el impacto sobre
esa imagen ha sido muy grande no es no
está claro cuánto le podrá perdonar la
sociedad argentina esto es verdad que
las sociedades con el tiempo muchas
veces se olvidan pero aquellos que por
ejemplo no pudieron despedir que
fallecieron en la pandemia en esas en
esas épocas por las restricciones y
muchas veces van a seguir pensando van a
seguir recordando que el presidente y su
pareja realizar una fiesta de cumpleaños
cuando la gente no se podía reunir ni
como decía acompañar la familia que
estuvieran enfermos e incluso ir a ir a
funerales así que es difícil saber
cuánto se lo perdonará la sociedad claro
también natalio argentina tuvo uno de
los funcionamientos más largos de
nuestra región cómo está la situación
ahora
no ahora es totalmente diferente pero
claro tiene que ver con que estamos en
un momento muy distinto de la pandemia
también y que todos aprendimos mucho el
gobierno aprendió mucho creo que hizo
una revisión o algunas de las personas
de lo que no pueden haber hecho una
revisión de cuán estricta debió haber
sido tal vez la cuarentena pero en este
momento estamos prácticamente en una
situación de casi absoluta normalidad a
pesar de que hay un incremento reciente
de los casos si de los casos no de los
fallecimientos ni de la presión sobre el
sistema de salud sobre todo por la
vacunación aquí en el país que es
bastante extensa